-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated
and Golden Globe
award-winning actress
for her work on "Black-ish."
The season finale
airs May 18th on ABC.
Let's take a look.
-Diane, as the driver,
what do you do to start?
-Address mirrors, start engine
hands and 10:00 and 2:00.
One lap around, stay alert
then park safely
next to strategically placed
safety trash cans.
-Ooh!
-Okay.
Girl, you ready.
-Yes.
-Okay, listen.
You're gonna make mistakes
All right?
You're gonna get frustrated.
But I am here to guide you
And also, I'm gonna have
a little bit of fun,
'cause this is
your first time because --
[ Engine starts ]
[ Clears throat ]
Have you...driven before?
-Not that you can prove.
-[ Chuckles nervously ]
Okay.
-Please welcome back
to the show,
our friend, Tracee Ellis Ross.
How are you, Tracee?
-Hi, Seth.
How you doing?
-I'm doing wonderful.
I last saw you in August.
And really hoped the next time
we'd see each other,
it would be in person,
and yet here we are again.
Although I do think
you're in a different room
-I think
I'm in a different room.
But I'm still in the same house.
I'm still in the same place.
But, yeah, I was hoping I woul
be there with you in person.
But we have made progress.
There's light
at the end of the tunnel.
I feel the vaccination hop
just wafting through the air
-I feel the same
sort of optimism.
And I do think it's bringing u
closer to seeing each othe
in the same room.
Speaking of rooms, true story,
does your --
your house
has a meditation room?
-My house
used to have a meditation room
-Oh, what happened?
-Well, it became the one roo
in the house that had, like,
doors on either side
for cross ventilation,
and I would put fans, air
purifier, open all the doors
and if I needed anyone
to come to the house,
that's where we would sit
if we couldn't be outside.
-Got you.
-So my meditation room
is now my whole house.
And now I just have --
I have to be, Seth, in a walking
meditation at all times.
-Oh, right.
Sure.
-Do you know?
Just have to practice
being present at all times
-Now, I feel like I read
that it was a boom time
this whole quarantine year
for people and meditating.
But as someone who meditated
before COVID hit,
did you find it was a good yea
for you in meditating?
-No, it was really hard
for me to sit.
I'm a sitting meditation gal
and I couldn't
quiet my mind enough.
I think I was in --
I mean, I realized
once I got the vaccination
that I was afraid --
like, terrified for a year
My nervous system,
my lower brain stem.
I was in fight or flight
for a year.
And so I couldn't
settle myself down enough
to sit on my cushions.
But I did a lot of
moving meditation
and breathing work,
which was good enough.
I have since been able
to sit in meditation again
-Were you emotional
when you got your vaccine?
-Yeah.
-I was emotional.
I felt a deep sense
of relief and gratitude.
I also kept --
I said this little prayer.
It was, "Thank you, science,
for stepping in and allowing m
to put down my rudimentary tools
to face this terrifying monster,
of locking myself in my hous
and being afraid of people."
I was so happy
to drop that mantle.
It has taken me time, 'cause
like, I don't know about you
but my experience is,
the little things that I d
out in the world, I think
I'm fine with my mask on.
And then I come home, and I'
in, like, a tailspin of anxiety,
and I'm convinced
that I've gotten COVID,
which reminds me of
the beginning of the pandemic,
when, like, every sensation of
your body, you were like -
[ Panting ]
But slowly creeping --
gently creeping my way forward
But, yeah, a deep sense
of gratitude and tears.
What about you?
-Oh, yeah, I got super choked up
when I got my first shot.
It was --
And it definitely surprised me
But I think I had the same thing
of I did not realize
how much fear had permeate
my existence for a year.
-Yeah. And, you know,
within this pandemic, of, like
being afraid of this imaginary
monster that wasn't imaginary,
but we couldn't see it,
was also...a lot of violence
a racial reckoning,
so, like, my nervous system,
it's -- I'm in this process of
trying to calm myself down
which I think is important
for all of us to acknowledge
Like, I keep trying
to have deep compassion
for other people and myself.
-I think that is a --
If that's the takeaway
of the last year,
that would be
a very good takeaway.
I am also happy to see that yo
took that step, that big step,
of getting on an airplane.
-I did, yes.
-Taking a trip out of L.A.
And I wanted to show a video
This is someone who's mayb
not traveled for a while.
Maybe forgot how you're
supposed to dress for a plane.
-Also, somebody who was
genuinely locked down.
I was a genuine
lockdown person.
I did not go to the market
I did not go anywhere.
I really did not
see anyone at all.
And I'm single and alone,
so it was, you know...
So going out into the worl
with other people,
I wanted to be prepared
and safe, Seth.
I wanted to be
prepared and safe!
-Well, let's take a look
at how you went about it.
Here's Tracee.
And there she is,
wearing a full helmet, wit
a mask on inside the helmet.
-Okay.
So, to be clear,
air filtration system
in the helmet, double mask
and that was in case I needed to
go to the bathroom on the plan
because I wanted
to be extra safe.
I also wiped down my seat,
put a seat cover,
and had an air purifier
I was also holding.
[ Clears throat ]
But I'm fine.
-Do you think people were
looking at you strangely?
Or was it impossible
to see their faces
through everything you had on?
-You know, Seth,
other people's opinion of me
was not my first priority.
My priority was my safety
and my comfort level.
And, therefore,
I took all precautions
and let other people's
points of view,
judgment, and shaming --
left those to themselves.
-May they have
the same compassion for yo
that you have for them, Tracee
-That's right, Seth!
That's right.
[ Both laugh ]
-Hey, how have --
Do you feel --
I mean,
are you seeing friends yet
Do you feel like
you've forgotten how to be -
Because I know you to be
a very gregarious person
in public and certainly
in social situations.
Has that come back?
Is it like riding a bike?
Or do you feel that it's rusty
-It's rusty.
-Yeah.
-I'm definitely rusty.
And I took two steps forward
one step back.
So what I have found is,
I'm still a person who will --
I have no shame about
putting my mask back on.
You know, even if we're outside.
I'm like, if it makes me fee
more comfortable, put it on.
I miss my friends, but I -
it's also, like, a process
Because I find that
it's the aftermath
that's the most difficult.
I'm fine while I'm in it.
And then, I get home,
and I'm like, "That was so
reckless and irresponsible!"
And now, you know --
And I was not.
As you can tell,
I take things quite seriously.
[ Both laugh ]
-You --
This is really incredible.
This is eight seasons of a show.
In any area --
any era, excuse me --
of television, eight seasons
is an incredible accomplishment.
Here's a photo -- I mostly
want to show this photo --
it's the show over the years
but it's also Anthony's bear
over the years.
Which is really --
-Yeah, so we -- on the 18th --
Yeah, look at this.
On the 18th is our season finale
of season seven.
And I can't believe
seven years has gone by.
But at the same time, I have
the marker of Anthony's beard.
-Yeah.
-And I will tell you that,
while we shot
during the pandemic, Anthony
because of the beard,
his mask would,
during rehearsal, start to
creep into his eyeballs.
-[ Laughs ]
-Because the mask --
There was no way to get
a mask over the beard.
And I was like,
"Anthony, can you see?"
"No. But I'm being safe."
[ Laughs ]
-Well, that -- Again, certainly,
that is to be valued
over the course
of this last year.
It is so wonderful to see you,
Tracee.
I hope next time,
one, either you're here,
or, two, we see yet another room
of your beautiful home.
-I would hope to be with you
in person, Seth.
-Let's aim for that instead.
The season finale of "Black-ish"
airs next Tuesday,
May 18th, on ABC.